knowledge is a powerful tool to become
knowledgeable you must ask good
questions you have advice for asking
good questions yeah I mean knowledge is
a powerful tool for sure yeah I mean
it's it's the master of tools right it's
where all your tools come from because
without knowledge there's nothing and
you know you take that one step further
and really knowledge is it's a weapon
it's the ultimate weapon and it trumps
all other weapons right thought is what
wins the mind is what wins the knowledge
is what wins and you absolutely you you
you gain knowledge by asking questions
right so my advice for asking questions
is pretty simple question everything
don't don't just accept anything as
truth question it all question
everything I tell my kids when they go
to school to sit in the front of the
classroom and when they when they when
they don't understand something the
second they don't understand something
just put your hand right up in there and
say I don't understand that I understand
that part can you go over that again and
that's how you need to be in life that's
how I try to be when you don't
understand a word break out a dictionary
and look it up if you don't understand
the concept break down the concept until
you do understand if you don't know how
something works dig into it until you do
know how it works
ask every question that comes to mind
and I'm not saying that you have to
blurt out why why why why this like a
five-year-old and everything you see but
yes ask those questions and learn and
most importantly question yourself
question yourself every day
ask yourself who who am i what have I
learned what have I created what forward
progress
have I made who have I helped what am i
doing to improve myself today
to get better faster stronger healthier
smarter ask yourself is this what I want
to be this is this all I've got is this
everything I can give is this going to
be my life and do I accept that
you gotta ask yourself those questions
those hard questions and you gotta
answer get an answer them truthfully and
you gotta realize that all of us all of
us can do better we can be better you
just gotta take that first step and that
first step is when you begin to ask
those questions so advice on asking
questions ask the hard questions
and ask the hard questions of yourself
and in the answers to those questions is
where you find that path the path to
progress and the path of freedom inside
your mind